l'une des figures du mouvement des gilet
jaune j'ai vraiment rodrigues a appelé à
de nouvelles manifestations
pas seulement à paris mais sur tout le
territoire de la métropole
donc j'ai appelé l'ensemble des deux ce
qui actionne aujourd'hui en france a
récupéré les péages à récupérer les
ronds-points et les différents centres
villes aujourd'hui partout en france ce
samedi 12 septembre pour pouvoir crier
notre colère bien sûr le plus
pacifiquement possible à lyon le ton est
donné sur facebook début des
manifestations dans l'après midi plus de
180 participants et près de 800
personnes intéressées à 14h un deuxième
rassemblement non déclaré a été lancé
sur les réseaux sociaux
le palais de justice est désigné comme
point de ralliement à paris les gilet
jaune espère je cite une convergence des
luttes dans une vidéo promotionnelle ces
derniers fournissent une liste de
numéros d'avocats en cas d'arrestation
plusieurs rendez vous sont donnés samedi
dans des lieux symboliques et ce malgré
l'interdiction des autorités parisiennes
en effet la préfecture de police
interdit tout rassemblement de personnes
se revendiquant du mouvement des gilet
jaune à partir du vendredi 11 septembre
à 18 heures et toute la journée de
samedi les plus grandes avenues et rues
de la capitale sont concernés